there was alleged that the newspapers
were not aware the large percentage of
the population of American citizens were
unhappy with the ruling establishment
did not feel their voices are being
heard and they voted against what
everybody thought was was the leading
candidate and instead voted for this
rank outsider a very unpredictable and
generally unpopular person this
businessman this egotist this rakish
character named Donald Trump I thought
what was missing from the newspapers and
I think more than that from Americans in
general who watched television who read
books to teach in universities who are
among the educated classes which ago
almost includes everybody these days the
reason I say that in my lifetime born in
1932 and becoming a journalist in the
1950s and at the time I became a
journalist the 1950s we journalists
whether we worked for the New York Times
of the fiddle of Enquirer the Chicago
Tribune were generally the first of our
family to have gone to college and when
I say college I do not mean Harvard Yale
Princeton Stanford
I mean Brooklyn College er in my case
the University of Alabama we were not
going to the elite colleges but we went
to college at all it was we were
considered scholars in our family but
what we were what we were not true today
but what we in the mid twentieth century
America we were outsiders we journalists
were of the outsider class whether we
were Italian heritage is me or Jewish or
African American or Spanish whatever and
we saw through the outside looking in
with our nose pressed against the glass
we looked inside at power privilege at
maneuverings within the political system
at hypocrisy at outright deceit we saw
all this and sometimes if we had courage
we wrote about and we did have courage
because most of us had come from parents
or grandparents who would knew who had
first-hand knowledge persecution in
foreign countries
who came to this country on the run and
brought with them the spirit of
unfairness and we as the inheritors of
their spirit when journalism we were the
children of those period of those people
we brought not cynicism but skepticism
of power and it was never our ambition
to be part of power because we were
chroniclers of power we were critics of
power we were viewers of power
we were outsiders well those days are
long long long gone what we have now 50
years beyond what I'm talking about the
group of journalists who go to the same
elite schools as the most privileged
people of power Obama was a college
professor Harvard man and he was
teaching while I'm president for the two
terms essentially teaching class to the
higher classes including the journalism
of his time now you have this ranked
foul-mouthed guy with this all this
awful blonde hair becoming elected and
the people in German oh god it's so
embarrassing it's like they I mean they
were so stunned as like having their
world is shattered and then why you're
so shattered why are you so stupid you
don't you realize that you join you
journalists are so blind you don't know
as journalists anything except being
educated from the time your you're
privileged little kids I mean even poor
people black people Hispanic still want
to be like the privileged white people
and what I'm getting at in her
long-winded way as the we journalists
have failed we're a failed profession
the pride that my generation took
being strong as a force against the
powers of prerogatives the powers of
privilege doesn't exist anymore
doesn't exist anyway the journalists now
want to be part of the power game they
want to get on Air Force One they want
to join Trump at 21 they want to have
that dinner 21 with it they want to be
clustered in Washington which is the
most most decadent city it's the most
evil empire if I were running Washington
a point I sometimes have granny has
ideas in the middle of the night if I
was ready what I would get half of those
reporters out of Washington break up the
washington press corps send them all
over to the state capitals we have 50
states put two reporters in every state
instead of covering Congress or the
cabinet order let the people who are
from these states report the mood of the
state's report the feelings the findings
the personalities that are in parts of
America that are not in in the main
mainstream and main light and we tell
our story not from the power brokers are
clustered Washington those privileged
power and generally rich people but were
tell something about the results of law
the results of privilege the results of
ignorance there was also of bad
decisions in war would cover injured
soldiers would cover the life of farmers
would cover a grease mechanic a guy that
some redneck sheriff somewhere and if we
knew the America that way we would not
be surprised by such an election as we
had in the aftermath of Obama's eight
years
[Music]